kortnee oh oh my god will you marry me
yes of course I will I love you so much
okay so Ben flash Nick and Courtney
Robertson may not have lived happily
ever after but Ben has moved on
thanks to tinder the former reality star
called in to huffington post's here to
make friends podcast and admitted that
he met his girlfriend Stephanie win by
swiping right on the dating app
congratulations on finding love somehow
despite not finding it on The Bachelor I
found it on a dating app I found it on a
dating app just swipe the right and then
couldn't be more smitten over Stephanie
they've been dating a year and a half
she's fantastic she's a wonderful family
she is starting nursing school here
pretty soon a nice normal life living a
quiet neighborhood in the city and you
know friends all around families up
north it's um that's pretty great the
former bachelor also had some advice for
people looking for love just keep
casting lines and find its time on
tinder who knew tell us what you think
of online dating on twitter using the
hashtag ET now